I think the Doritos in the Cheetos it's
gonna make it real nice
swaggy this is the tasty and poussey
cooking show
we welcome you here at busty we're very
glad that you joined us and we actually
say instead of Hussein and tasty is
pasty that is the name of our show as
you can see we are both qualified chefs
by chef Han I'm not a big fan of
mushrooms no I would eat me rocks from
Doritos one Cheetos two different kind
of orange cheese but they both worn [ __ ]
we have pasta and some beans and some I
don't know what this is Oh black pepper
just go ahead oh look this won't even
it's like congealed but it's okay you're
just gonna put all of it that's the
first step then we're gonna get a spoon
- Latrice yes it does poussey ha this is
real Velveeta it's not it wait that was
a trick question and not make cheese do
you oh well congratulations let's just
mix up some stuff yes here aren't you
take the mushrooms good yeah but we
gotta put a little bit in them yeah you
hear that sizzling I like to read outs
go get a little bit of that you day this
is look like wonderful
beans you'll never go wrong with beans
except sometimes I feel like a real chef
Mac like shoes I love to cook I love
cooking salmon and whipping up I love
kale whether it's killed I love going
over Danielle how I have her cook for me
I wish I could see what's happening in
this pot right now cuz it's magic I
think we need more cheese I don't want
to taste this part mmm cuz I'm not ready
and this is close to a mac and cheese is
actually more yellow than it is orange
but that's okay so I think it's time to
taste it Samir will you be our taste
tester here you gotta eat it with your
hands because we're not prepared on the
pasty show this is for y'all
those be giving I must item dee-dum
Doritos and cheetah make it was up
alright here we go
I'm nervous
mmm it's really good you know I hope you
enjoyed your time joining I needed this
eight one method tasty poussey show come
peacefully yes that's the reason we have
aprons